that's my asset Limor no kids no family
100% accurate reliable you mark him or
he mark you mark test ego is a
world-renowned action star he was in the
raid movies choreographs all of his own
fights he's a big star all over the
world for a reason and I went in saw the
film and I was just mesmerized by him
and by the soul and the texture and the
emotion and the physical brutality all
kind of you just had it there's
something there and see if a hundred
guys fight but one of them kind of
touches your soul ego definitely had
that quality Eco is a master of pinch
oxalá which is an Indonesian martial art
has a lot of circular blocks this is not
like your basic karate or Taekwondo
which is very hard
see lots known for having knives they
use all sorts of things weapons there's
so many talented fight choreographers
and and we used several of them Nikko
really ran it well as interested as to
watch the American guys support ego so
the chemists very interesting like
laboratory Eco is basically the next
generation of Jackie Chan and people who
don't already know him will definitely
know him and what he can do from this
movie
you go brought his AGame and I'm really
happy to be a part of helping bring eco
to a larger audience
you